This is the Chris Abraham Show.
Hey there, This is The Chris
Abraham Show.
My name is Chris Abraham.
It is season five, episode 58,
and the only reason 58 might be
special to me is because my
dearly beloved dad, Sorry,
Robert John Abraham.
Bob.
Bob Abraham.
My personal Hemingway.
Died at 58 in June of 1995 when
I was 25.
So poor went out to you Daddy,
daddy, daddy do today is gonna
be boring or interesting or self
indulgent or humble brag or all
the above or none of the above.
I did make it to.
So yesterday I was knackered.
Yesterday I did run a park run.
I almost went out because I was
so knackered from Friday and
Thursday.
I don't know why, but when I
woke up on Saturday, I'm like,
I'm running late.
I'm not feeling it.
So I was gonna even take an Uber
to Roosevelt Island.
But then I'm like, come on
Chris.
So I pumped my tires and jumped
on the bike, which doesn't have
Spd's or cages anymore.
It's just big.
Plastic super duper big like
flat mountain bike BMX pedals
and my bar horn Nitto is that
right Bars and it 5 miles to
Roosevelt Island.
Got there.
Plenty of time put on my hi viz
orange tail, Walker Vest said.
Hello to the beautiful South
African family that I've
adopted. 2 adorable blonde
little daughters, lovely mum and
dad who stays at home every
Saturday in order to enjoy
football and rugby.
Manly man, love it so I get to
be Uncle Chris.
I am a tail Walker so I didn't
get to hang out with the girls
yesterday, which was sad, but I
got some hugs and they were off
on holiday so they were there
and adorable and wise and smart
and confident as girls Well
beyond there.
I think 567 year old 10 is the
other and respect for wearing
flip flops to a park run.
Cuz they know they're
volunteering and not running, so
the littlest one wore a Cape the
whole time because she's
volunteered 10 times.
So they honored her.
And I did tail walking and it
was fun, but I whacked my little
toe and not whacked it.
But it was the day before, on
Friday, I I definitely could
tell that I had a huge.
Water like blister and tried to
pop it.
But then it was bad yesterday
and by the time I had a call at
11.
So I just sat on a bench in the
middle of the glorious beautiful
blue day.
I sat in the middle of Roosevelt
Island National Park in front of
President Roosevelt in all of
his glory and got extreme
amounts of sun and talked to the
gang from.
Elefante Marketing for some work
I'm doing for Elefante
Marketing.
And then, oh man, my my
hamstrings are toast.
So and that'll mean something
later.
So I finally I met a girl named
Becca.
She has a beautiful Teuton Noir
Specialized bike, and she is
Teuton Noir from her helmet to
her to her toes.
And she was smashing and
beautiful and wonderful and cool
and hip and young and happening.
And she loved on my bike and I
loved on her bike.
And I made fun of her for
wearing Teuton noir.
But then she made a fun of me
for wearing Teuton noir.
And then we I tried to sell her
on coming to the next park run.
And then we parted ways.
And I say this out loud cuz I'm
terrible with names.
So I remember her name is Becca.
And she's adorable and wonderful
and cool and charming and
friendly and vivacious and all
those things.
She's also, I think tall anyway,
tall but good tall.
Not like 8 feet tall.
And then I rode my bike to
Crystal City cuz I hadn't eaten.
All I had was watering coffee in
the morning.
I didn't even have you know,
what I'm gonna start doing now
is before my workouts, I'm gonna
pound some protein powder.
And coffee.
Protein powder with coffee.
So that's my new drug of choice
before, and I'll be talking
about F45 training in a second.
So anyway, I bicycled to Crystal
City, went to the Crystal City
Whole Foods, and just like,
maxed out on everything that was
meat.
Because I'm sort of ostensively
on a carnivore diet, even though
protein powder isn't very like
there's.
Additives.
And it's not carnivore
completely, but let's just say
anytime I eat food and it'll be
mostly carnivore and then I'll
some I'll add to that protein
powder and maybe like
preworkout.
Maybe I'll order a tub of
So I got home.
No, no, a full story.
I ate an entire, like, medium
box of like, chicken chicken.
And cod.
And like all this, like sundry
meat, was whatever was at the
hot bar chowed down.
Gave myself an hour of recovery
from that and then wasn't
feeling it.
So I jumped on my bike and went
over to where the Chickfila is,
across the street from
Nordstrom's at that bus place.
And I've got like $50.00 on my
metro trip card.
So I just waited for the 16M bus
cuz for you.
For you who don't know there is
a quas.
There's enough of a formidable
hill from Crystal City, Pentagon
City to where I live on the Pike
that right now it's just a pain
in my butt and it dissuades me.
So I was just.
I was feeling tapped out from 10
miles of riding, sitting in the
sun and 5K of walking like all
in the morning that I just
threw.
The beautiful thing about DC
buses is they've got free two
free bicycle spots on the front
of every bus and they're
underutilized.
So there's always a spot for
what what we should what should
we name my bike?
It's a 2010 Surly Steamroller.
2011 2010 2011 Surly Steamroller
What is his or her name?
She probably already has the
name, but I don't remember it.
So anyway, I threw her on the
front of the bus.
I brought it home and I
honestly, I crashed for how many
hours?
Like, my goodness, I crashed for
a number of hours.
Let me see.
La La La La La La la.
Alright, I slept for almost 3
hours. 2 hours, 54 minutes from
honestly it's called poor sleep.
But I slept from almost 2:00 PM
to almost 530 like like I
completely wrecked my day.
And then I was able to go to
sleep after that at 9:30.
So like I didn't kill my sleep.
The night before I had only had
around 7 hours of sleep, which
is normal for people, not me,
not like me, but I try to get a
full 8 or 7 1/2 or whatever, so
whatever.
My my sleep last night was 81,
so it's considered considered
good.
And then I woke up early this
morning.
I woke up at 641 because I had
an O900 very my very first like
functional training class at
this this class like this this
this global like like
orangetheory called F45.
And there's one that's 10
minutes away by walking in
Penrose Square.
So I woke up.
I decided not to eat anything
because I was afraid of vomiting
in the class.
And I I basically had four
scoops of of of protein and the
coffee that was left over in the
pot from yesterday that I didn't
drink and and then a bunch of
water.
I packed my.
My Domkey bag.
Like my Domkey camouflage bag,
I've packed it with a my
Gatorade towel, my NAL gene
bottle.
I filled the NAL gene bottle
which is 33 oz, with two scoops
of of relight electrolytes and
then slept over there and met
Laura.
Laura, Lauren, Laura and she
gave me the update and it's 45
minutes.
Today was 45 minutes of pretty
like weight trainee stuff and my
knees are garbage and my quads
are garbage.
So I did a lot of a lot of
adapted workout and it was fine.
The woman next to me hate.
I don't, I don't remember what
her name is.
Yikes.
I will remember next time.
But she.
Like was so motivating.
Everybody was so supportive.
You're really not interactive,
even though that you have like a
a a pod of people who are doing
the same exercises the same
time.
She was always supportive,
always instructional.
She's done 42 workouts.
So like, there's and.
And.
I had plenty of Laura's time.
I had plenty of this woman's
time.
I feel like everybody was super
supportive.
Everybody was trying to give me
alternative exercises.
I could have just stood there
and whittled my butt and it
would have been OK Like there
were a lot of pistol squats.
I don't know.
Pistol squats are super
intimidating for me.
Like I would do alternate
things.
Like, there was this I I did a I
did planks.
I did, I did everything pretty
much for the first half, the
first half of the way through.
I felt like 1,000,000 bucks for
the second-half.
I became sweaty MC sweat face I.
Towards the end I started
getting brittle and shaky and
and not until so I paced myself
pretty well.
It wasn't until the last couple
exercises where I started to
fall apart and then afterwards I
stayed for another 10 minutes or
another 5 minutes and Laura ran
the people who stayed behind
through some amazing stretches.
She told me at the very end,
she's like, I wanna talk to you
afterwards.
And I'm like, Oh no, I'm gonna
get cut.
She's gonna be like, we never
cut anybody.
But you're like, you know, bad
knee, Mick, bad knee face.
And like, you're totally getting
cut.
But she just wanted to figure
out if I was into it, if I liked
it.
She was gonna sign me up for
like, fully, like unlimited.
But then when I got into the
into the tool, I'm like I could
get under there seven days for
$7.00.
So I did that and then
afterwards I'm gonna commit to
unlimited, which is around $55 a
week, 5055 dollars a week.
And I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it earlier.
I'm gonna do it later.
The only day I'm not gonna do it
is on Saturdays, cuz on
Saturdays I'm doing park run,
right?
So every day of the week I'm
gonna do some semblance of 45
minute to an hour.
I'll never do an hour cuz
Saturday is an hour but.
Every day I'm gonna do 45
minutes of some sort of like
high intensity training and I'm
just gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna maybe slack.
I'm gonna maybe like putts out.
I'm gonna maybe tap out.
I'm just gonna say, OK, 45
minutes every day of the week,
except Saturday when I do a bike
ride and a park run trail, a
tail walk every day of the week
I'm gonna do something.
Then afterwards I I.
On the way there, I ordered a
giant espresso, but I didn't get
any of it in me before the
class.
But I had it afterwards and it
was lukewarm.
That's fine.
I went out into Penrose, Penrose
Square.
I basked like a basilisk.
I basked like a skink.
I basked like this, the green
tailed skink that we saw
yesterday on Roosevelt Island.
And I basked and basked and
basked.
And then I ordered.
A ham and cheese omelet from Bob
and Edith's and I had it was
extremely expensive because I
didn't get any of the carbs.
I just got an omelet and a side
of sausage and a side of bacon
and I maxed out my protein bead
an hour after the workout and
went and walked and grabbed that
and chomped on that.
And then set my intermittent
fasting alarm so that I won't
eat till tomorrow after my next
F45 workout.
And I feel like these high
intensity workouts are a little
bit like Ozempic.
Let me explain.
Ozempic basically makes you sick
to your stomach so you don't
wanna eat.
Honestly, these kind of high
intensity workouts make me sick
to my stomach and not wanna eat
like an hour after the workout.
I knew I needed to get calories
into me.
So I like, I kind of stuffed the
ham and cheese omelet and the
sausage and the bacon into me
like, like like like like
stuffing into the butt of a
Turkey.
But like, I'm feeling gross,
like I need to just eat enough,
drink enough hydration and salts
and stuff.
And I was thinking I would need
to take a nap afterwards, but I
just came back.
And through all of my stuff into
the shower so I can kind of
mitigate, mitigate all the
laundry by washing as I go.
Because I told you, one of my
eccentricities is that I shower
using Dawn dishwashing
detergent.
Everything in the in the
apartment is Dawn dishwashing
detergent.
So I also tend to wash my unit
my my my uni suits.
And this time since I swamped
out my stretchy shorts and my I,
I've been using tech tshirts so
everything goes in the shower
and I do.
I do a scrubby scrub, Ruby rub,
rinsy rinse, squeezy squeeze,
hang those bad boys up, do a
rinsy rinse of me, and then
towel down.
And my day is started.
So that's it I.
Feel like I've survived?
The eye of the tiger.
Bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum
bum.
So accordingly I have my next
class tomorrow at 0 dot dark 30,
which is bloody crazy cuz I'm a.
Dummy Mcdum face and we'll see
what happens.
Como dear, my next class is
Manana and it is tomorrow at
07/15 and wish me luck is called
the MVP workout.
Hey Google, what is the MVP
workout at a F45 training?
I don't know, but I found these
results on search.
Alexa, what is the MVP worked
out in an F45 trading?
From CNN Bascom The MP please
design for use in sales and
there's many in the making.
Sensations already Us in the
purse West by the way.
Second lap team number to change
while you will hear them.
Same equipment yes two new
notifications from Amazon
shopping.
A shipment has arrived including
jump rope.
There's a low price offer from
your saved for later list.
The new ME Fitness Suspension
Workout Cards instructional
fitness deck for women and men
is currently $20.35.
The deal will be at least 15%
off that price.
It goes live in 18 hours and 54
minutes.
If you're interested in this
deal when it's available, I can
either remind you or buy it for
you.
Say remind me later or buy it
for me.
Buy it for me?
Well, it didn't work anyway.
That was fun.
That didn't work, so apparently.
MVP is a fixed equipment cardio
session with the twist on the
second lap.
The even numbered stations will
change while the while still
using the same equipment.
So I don't know what that's
about, so I'm gonna go in a
little early.
If if the class is tomorrow at
7:15 AM, then I'm gonna get
there at, oh 700.
And I'm probably gonna order a
big espresso that I won't drink
and we'll see how it goes.
Love to you guys.
Like I said, I'm £295.00 so I
felt really heavy, I felt really
belabored, but I felt really
motivated and I left there in a
positive way.
So if you're as intimidated and
skit, if you are as intimidated
and scared and like.
Afraid of F45 for being too
intense and something that's
gonna make your heart explode
out of your chest.
Or if you're gonna be laughed at
for being the loser.
Or if you're gonna be mocked for
being heavy, heavy, or chubby,
or out of shape or old, or.
Or if you feel like you're gonna
be fat shamed or fit shamed or
aid shamed if you're not.
Like a complete CrossFit, studly
mixed, studly face.
Then don't feel that way.
I'm 53 years old.
I have pretty bad knees.
I'm 295 pounds, I'm extremely
underdeveloped and unfit, and my
hamstrings are tight.
And my my legs.
Even though they've been my best
asset, they are shriveled and I
am undermuscled.
I'm falling apart.
And I was able to do it because
I had the support of a great
coach.
I had support of the woman, the
charming and wonderful woman,
who was in my class with me,
whose name I hate myself for
forgetting.
And it was a supportive
environment.
And you run your own race and
you do your own exercises, and
you're only responsible for
yourself and there's no wall of
competition.
That's not a thing where you're
wearing a heart rate monitor.
Even though I run my own heart
rate monitor on my Garmin
Instinct Solar, I run while I'm
there.
I run the cardio.
Aside from that, you're running
your own wet race.
Nobody's looking at you.
Nobody's making fun of you.
Everybody's looking up at either
the LED screens, like the the
the screens or they're looking
at their own thing or they're
having their own suck or they're
doing their own workout and
everybody at the end gives you a
high five.
It's a very very love based
environment and I and and I
suggested for everybody at all
ages.
I guess the legalese is you
should check with your doctor
first.
But if you are okay they give
you plenty of time to mop up,
they give you plenty of time for
hydration and 45 minutes goes
really quickly.
If you go in early you can do
some stretching if you are.
If you have a little bit of time
afterwards between your class
and the next class, the coach
might give you a little bit of
stretching and warming down.
It's a 5 out of five.
I'm very excited about it.
I joined and you should check
out to see if there's an F45
near you.
And there are plenty promotions.
There's a free seven days.
There's all kinds of promotions.
And even here, there's one in
Shirlington, there's one in
Crystal City, there's one in
Pentagon City, there's one in
Clarendon.
So they're all over.
I'll talk to you soon.
Lots of love.
Bye, bye.
Well, thanks for listening to
The Chris Abraham Show.
This is Chris Abraham season
five, episode 58.
Love you, Dad.
Bye.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.